في هذه الاثناء قال رئيس جنوب افريقيا سير
رم فوزه ان قرار محكمه العدل الدوليه ملزم
لاسرائيل ويجب احترامه من قبل كل الاعضاء
بمعاهده منع الاباده الجماعيه وقال انه
يجب على اسرائيل ان تتخذ اجراءات لوقف
التحريض على الاباده والسماح بوصول
الخدمات الاساسيه الى
غزه نقول اليوم مره اخرى انه لا ينبغي ان
تكون هناك ابدا ابدا اي اعمال اباده
جماعيه بافلا من العقاب ودون مسائله
والمجتمع الدولي يتفرج بعد هذا الحكم
ينبغي ان يكون هناك جهد جماعي من اجل
تحقيق وقف اطلاق النار وبعث مفاوضات من
اجل حل نهائي على اساس حل الدولتين لتمكين
الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين من ان يعيشوا
جنبا الى جنب ويحقق الفلسطينيون حق تقرير
المصير في جنوب افريقيا نفكر كلنا في دور
المجتمع الدولي وهناك ملايين في العالم
دعموا الدعوه التي رفعناها وهناك دول عبرت
عن رغبتها في ان تكون طرفا في القضيه امام
محكمه العدل الدوليه